وللحديث اب عن ابرز الاحداث هذه المره في
بريطانيا لعام 2022 تنضم الينا بالندن
زميله عروب عبد الحق مراسله صباح العربيه
عروبي يسعد صباحك كنتي معنا طيره هذه
السنه لتغطيه احداث لندن من استقاله بونس
جونسون الى وفاه الملكه اليك الكلمات في
اخر اطلاله هذه السنه مع صباح العربيه
صباح الخير سهام وصباح الخير نادين بالفعل
يعني هذا العام على بريطانيا التي يعني قد
تكون من اكثر الدول التي شهدت ازمات
سياسيه وتقلبات هذا العام سواء من الناحيه
السياسيه او من ناحيه العائله الملكيه
ويبدو ان الاضطرابات هي ستكون العنوان
الاكبر
للحكومه الجزائريه في عام 2003 من الجانب
السياسي طبعا هو اقل ما يوصف بان الوضع
السياسي هنا في بريطانيا
اربعه وزراء ماليه فقط في اقل من شهرين
هذا العام همم بدات هذه الفوضى ربما في
يوليو تحديدا عندما قال رئيس الوزراء
الصادق على خلفيه تراكم ازمات وقضائع كان
قد مر بها مثل همم فضيحه
يعني تحرش طالت بعض المقربين منه في
الحكومه همم
ااا رئاسه الحكومه من بعده لتكون بذلك
ثالث امراه تقود بريطانيا ولكنها اكثرهم
مده حكم يعني بعد 45 يوم فقط استقالت
رئيسه الوزراء بعد همم يعني همم سميت بي
كراسه
من الناحيه الاقتصاديه
باقاله وزير الماليه المقربين لها وانتهى
الفستقالتها ايضا ليتسلم وبعد ذلك في سباق
سريع لحزب المحافظ وهو الذي يبدو بانه
مواجهه اكبر تحدياته همم همم من خلال
الاضطرابات التي تتسارع وحيدتها خلال
الاسابيع الشهور الماضيه حشرات الاضرابات
شهدتها قطاعات مختلفه بريطانيا هذا الشهر
وتهديد المزيد من الاضطرابات في بدايه
العام ما بتسوى في قطاع الصحه في البريد
في قطاع السكك الحديديه وغيرها اما من
ناحيه العائله الملكيه فيبدوا بانها ايضا
شهدت العديد من التقلبات والاحداث
التاريخيه همم العائله الملكيه شهدت اول
يوبيل 30 لها عندما احتفلت الملكه
اليزابيث الرحله بمروج اكثر من 70 عام على
تواليها العرش البريطاني بعد ثلاثه اشهر
رحلات الملكه اليزابيث في سبتمبر من عام
2022 وفي مقتل يعني طبعا مهيب همم
ننهيها
الذي يعني فجر قنبله من العيار الثقيل
بالنسبه للعائله الملكيه التي تواجه هذا
التحدي
العائليه العام المقبل نعود اليك